my great friend from the worldwide
leader in sports with the latest on
the national football league and so much
more adam schefter how are you adam
hold the responsible happy 41st
anniversary to you to jim craig down
michael
obviously remember exactly where i was
when all that transpired i was in the
basement of my house in belmont new york
and it was a it was friday and
obviously if you remember back then the
game was on tape delay
that's right social media didn't exist
and so the results had come in
but you didn't know exactly what
happened in abc
or i think it was abc saving the game to
play it later
and what people forget is that wasn't
the gold medal game the gold medal game
was sunday against
finland i believe yes
that's correct and it's just like every
and everybody thinks that world series
ended when the ball went through
buckner's legs or tyree had the
game-winning catch in the super bowl
these are just big moments that actually
didn't win everything and because you
and i have
the same uh same childhood same
upbringing adam i was in the basement in
staten island new york of my parents
house
yeah and my brother the old my older
brother
knowing it was tape delayed we we turned
off all the traffic and weather together
radios
that my parents always listened to in
the house to make sure we did not have
the uh results spoiled
because it was tape delay yeah no it's
um
it was it was an incredible time again i
mean i could see my surroundings i could
see that
dark dank basement that i was in
the old beaten up tv that i watched it
on
i was just incredible as a lifelong
memory to see
what transpired that weekend in lake
placid and just incredible i really
remember all of it and
obviously uh like so many people we were
all
mesmerizing fixated by so much that came
out all the books and shows and
documentaries and
and it's one of those things you could
never get enough of so good for you for
getting the money else you should
mention rich yes sir
every quarter i get a quarterly royalty
check for my
unbelievable appearance in the longest
yard the movie it's like
three dollars and 33 cents yes sir comes
every quarter
and i always look forward to my royalty
checks i just gave him my bank and kept
my piggy bank here
you've got it you've got to instagram
out the next one adam
you just uh just do it just when you get
you get one of them just
just lay it on me you know and every
time
every time i get i'm like okay here's my
check for two dollars
in 41 cents and i wonder what adam
sandler
dude i think the same thing whenever i
open a csi miami for five cents like
what does david caruso make i mean he
only made 3 000 of them
unbelievable oh i'm out thanks for look
bud uh
i love i know you're busy man all the
time so when you call in in a february
when it's a quiet time i appreciate it
although it's never required time
obviously
in the nfl we appreciate we appreciate
the quiet times rich and this
this seemingly seems to be one but that
can change in a moment's notice in this
league so we'll see well i said let's
hit on some things that happened last
week well i was off and
you know your a comment that i think you
made on a
a radio appearance over the weekend in
philadelphia certainly leapt out at me
where you said
that doug peterson and carson wentz did
not speak for
anywhere of a period of time of from
eight weeks to ten weeks
that that's the case between those two
multiple multiple multiple weeks
uh again
they communicated they texted uh but i
don't think they spoke
for a period of time at least that's how
it was relayed to me right you
we are only as good as what we've been
told so sure somebody told that to me
right i don't know where they got it
from but um
look there there was a you know
everybody can
dress it up however they want and say
that everybody respond with each other
but the truth matters they weren't fine
with each other they just weren't
it just was not a normal
relationship the way you'd want your
head coaching quarterback to have their
relationship
so it is right and by the way doug
peterson's not there anymore
carson wentz isn't there anymore and
it's really remarkable
to think that a team and an organization
that has had as much success
as the eagles have had in recent years
winning a super bowl winning a division
going to the playoffs um almost getting
back to another nfc championship game
and and now like these parts have been
discarded and just
thrown about and they've moved on from
from so many of them it's just
it's really incredible how quickly uh
it's all come apart for an organization
that has been
and has had as much success as the
eagles have had so again i i'm wondering
where
where the tension came from or what is
the the basis of the tension between
peterson and wentz
and you know discussing it now i know
you know the eagles will say over and
over again
as is their right and usually a team's
want that they're turning the page but
the fact that a page needed to be turned
at all
for a team that's just a couple of years
three years removed from winning the
super bowl
uh so because the number of times that
peterson took
the um slings and arrows
uh standing up in front of the media to
say it still wentz's job when wence was
clearly clearly uh i guess the best way
to put it was
uh off kilter and the i guess
less generous way to put it was just
disintegrating
that where did that come from the basis
of the tension
best you can tell adam i you know rich
i i think it's a compilation
of a number of factors i think it uh
it's hard to know the exact origins
but i would say that i don't know that
the selection of jalen hurts
helped the situation and it certainly
seemed like
carson didn't react to that favorably
and it seems like it was reflected
in his level of confidence and in his
performance
now it's hard for me to imagine that
it's just that like
how could that be right right but
so i'm sure there are many layers to
this many layers
uh of course i'm not smart enough to
know all of them
i just know they existed and everybody
who watched them
knows that there were things there right
so i i don't know that we'll ever get
the full truth on that
because i think everybody does want to
just move on and go their own way
but there were issues
carson came apart it's why they
were willing to unload him and why his
value
obviously was not what it would have
been when
if they had ever wanted to watch him
which who would have thought that ever
would have been the case when he was
competing for an nfl mvp award
like the guy went from on top of the nfl
world to the eagles having
a shortage of teams
interested in him and one of the biggest
quarterback buying markets that will
ever see in an offseason
there was one team one team that made an
offer on
the colts adam schefter here
on the rich eisen show meanwhile across
state as you just said
uh about how uh remarkable a turnaround
or disintegration
uh with wence and the eagles um was
just over a few years spent how about
across state
uh adam where the steelers go from 11-0
last remaining undefeated team in 2020
to last week where the general manager
of the pittsburgh steelers kevin colbert
essentially would only allow for big
ben's future
or current state that he's a an alive
human being
who uh breathes and can fog up a mirror
on a contract
currently with the steelers that was
essentially all cobert would allow is
what it seemed to me
how did you take his comments from last
week that there's
still miles to go here potentially for
big ben to
continue on with the only franchise he's
ever known and one too
strange because if they want him back
for all that he's done for them and
they've done for him
all kevin colbert had to say was he's
our quarterback
we've got a lot of work to do and we'd
love to have ben back
it's amazing rich there are a few things
just
general themes that you could apply to
any situation i can't believe
how many times somebody's gotten in
front of the media since the season
ended and said something that
left you scratching your head like that
like that
like what is that and also what's
amazing to me is
again the disintegration of the eagles
do you think the franchise is in say um
slorum park new jersey or cleveland ohio
or uh miami florida would
kill for what the eagles have done
recently like
and yet in philadelphia uh
they want to destroy people they they
want people fired they want the
organization overrun
they want to set it on fire and
and and in pittsburgh it's not entirely
dissimilar either like
they were 11-0 they were rolling they
were as good as any team in football and
because they
looked so horrendous down the stretch
okay well maybe it's time to move on
let's get rid of people
and i just think the league is that the
noise surrounding the league is
louder than it's ever been the scrutiny
of
each organization is greater than it's
ever been
the hysteria that surrounds each team is
more hysterical than it's ever been and
i think that contributes to some of this
like do you think and and i'm just
wondering i don't know the answer to
this
if all this had transpired in
philadelphia
15 years ago would they have run off
carson wench
a few years later would everybody
associated with that super bowl win
be gone or on the way out like would
that would that have happened i'm asking
you right i don't know
here's so so let me i guess let's let's
pull on this a little bit adam schefter
um i think the brady and
victory in tampa uh in which every
single person who scored a touchdown in
the super bowl for the first time was
a free agent that wasn't on the team the
year before i think everybody's saying
well
if we make the right moves we could be
two three four moves away from going
from
500 or barely being 500 to winning it
all
and that's why i think that people are
maybe willing to throw
the baby out with the bathwater quicker
in a league that's already known for
that
um it's just that this is big ben though
i mean this is
this is you know he's basically saying
i'll play for nothing
and they're basically like well we got
to talk about this cap number and the
cap is going to be
contracting due to covet maybe put it
all together and that's what you're
talking about
i i i guess and i listen i love honesty
and i love transparency
and i love people talking to the media
that's great
but i don't understand why kevin colbert
would say that now maybe he was trying
to deliver a message on
but i i just i don't see the need to do
that i just don't see the need to do
that
it could have been so simple as
he's meant so much to this organization
and we need to work together to try to
figure this out unless they don't want
him
but i don't think that's the case so
again you know we'll see
but yeah it's just one more quarterback
vlog on the quarterback fire that's
burning brightly this offseason
adam shaw it'll keep it'll keep your
show very warm
adam schefter here on the rich eisen
show and your and your uh
handheld devices uh very warm uh as well
so
um and then of course everything we just
mentioned i think compel
pales in comparison to what's going on
with desean watson because we never seen
somebody age 25
sign a big huge contract like that and
then turn around a year later and say i
want out
and there's a new coach and a new
general manager coming in he doesn't
even want to talk to them
where do things stand on that adam as
you and i are talking right now yeah
exactly where they've been and exactly
where they will be for a little bit of
time which is that detections
are intent upon not trading him
and he's intent upon not playing for
that team again
and so you tell me how that plays out
over time
and when it reaches ahead and when it
reaches crescendo and i i don't know the
answer that nobody knows
you know the texans could say hey we'll
sit on you as long as it takes until you
come back here
and he could say i don't really care
i know what i've experienced and i know
what i believe about you i'm not coming
back there
now we've seen this before with other
players
and every player is different it it
unfolds different
we're also living in a different day and
age and i don't know that there's ever
been a player
as talented as deshawn in the position
he's in
that has been willing to go to the mat
and go to the distance for the team
so i i don't know how that plays itself
out i do know that
in my mind the first real natural
deadline that would come along
would be coming up to the draft because
if you are the texans and you are even
open to the idea that you would move on
from him and by the way they've given no
indication so far that that is the case
all this talk about desean watts being
traded which again
we've had you've had everybody's had has
been media generated because
we can look into the horizon
and see what could be out there whereas
the texans aren't even looking into the
horizon
they are living in the moment
they're living they're living in the
moment hoping that their phone buzzes
with a text from number four
saying let's chat you know and so that
ain't happening so let me ask you
let me ask you this adam has he
delivered a list to them uh
that these are the teams i want because
the number of times uh he would he'd
love to go to the jets
no he wouldn't or he'd love to go to the
dolphins no i actually prefer the
broncos
does something like that exist you know
what's funny i i i continue to see
reports
like the miami dolphins are interested
in the sean watson
report and i think to myself hold on
let me spell it out to you right now
rich yes every team
in the nfl with a quarterback question
is interested in deshaun watson breaking
news okay you
list the teams the jets the dolphins the
panthers the niners the bears
everyone with a question is interested
in desean watson
breaking okay we can put that to bed
right
everybody would love to have him
everybody
including the houston texans
so has he delivered a list to them best
you you know
i i don't i don't know that okay i don't
know that
um i i don't know that they're at that
level yet
um i don't know how deshawn and his
people
have decided to navigate this dance in
the coming weeks
um at some point i would think
that either deshawn or his
representation
would go to the texans and deliver them
in the strongest language possible we
are never going to play for your
organization again
you might want to trade us and when you
say the list of teams
what i've sensed and talked to various
people is that the list of teams is not
as short
as it would be for somebody like
matthew stafford or even carson wentz
who wants to go to indy
i i think deshawn is pretty wide open
on going to a lot of different places as
long as that place is not houston
unbelievable it's just crazy last one
for you adam uh before i let you go sir
um again the salary cap is expected to
be far less than uh normal times normal
years non-covet etc
so on and so forth give me some names
that might be surprise cuts just because
you know ordinarily of course this
player would be on the team
um give me give me give me somebody that
we might hear go oh my gosh
i can't believe that person is now a
free agent with somebody like say j.j
watt
give me one give me one rich we go
through every team
and i don't think it's that hard to come
up with some of the names and
many teams multiple teams you have to do
i don't want to just throw out a name
uh i think uh
i i would just say this that you are
probably looking at one of the biggest
if not the biggest buyer's market
in the history of free agency because
what you're going to see is the elite
players get paid
and obviously there's going to be a lot
of rookies
that are going to be drafted that are on
the minimum contracts and the middle
class player the veteran guy who gets
released
i think is going to be in a tough spot
because
that cap is gonna have to come from
somewhere and
they're not gonna compromise on paying a
guy like
dak prescott or chris godwin
or the elite of the elite that come
along every year that are
the top dozen twenty two dozen free
agents
but that next level i think it's a very
very tough year
to be a free agent and next year
probably will be a tough year to be a
frasier but
the goal would be you want to get to
about 2023
and have the new tv money kick in and
have the cap
skyrocket up and once that happens it's
going to be a great time to be a free
agent
not going to be a great time to be a
free agent this offseason unless
you are an elite talent all right i lied
last minute for you adam
the fact that drew brees is not retired
yet is is there any
any there there that he might actually
be going back and forth on this
and well here's the thing on drew bridge
last year
he went into the saints at the pro bowl
the coaching staff
and they cried because that was his last
game
the pro bowl he was retiring and they
took some time off
and lo and behold he came back in march
and by the way if he hadn't come back
i really believe that there's a chance
that tom brady would have been the same
quarterback this year
and he would have been playing in new
orleans but that that's a different
story
and so he came back now
what is going through his mind once he
steps away
there are so many players that that plan
to retire want our tire
and then to actually get him to it it's
not a simple thing
and so i'm not telling you he is i still
i still think he will retire
but i don't think these things are just
black and white like
he's ready to just go out the door just
yet even though i think ultimately that
will be the decision
adam you the man love you you be well
love you rich right
happy 40 happy 41. that's right next
time next time i uh we get to see each
other in person
you're spending your royalty checking a
cup of coffee for me done i'll see you
soon
you take care adam you're the man that's
adam schefter at adam schefter here
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here